OH MY GOD.
YES.
>> THOSE ARE THE EXCITED GASPS
OF A 13 YEAR OLD FROM OKLAHOMA
WHO APPEARED TO BEAT THE VIDEO
GAME TETRIS IN A YOUTUBE VIDEO
THAT HAS GONE VIRAL.
WILLIS GIBSON IS BELIEVED TO BE
THE FIRST HUMAN GAMER TO REACH
LEVEL 157 OF THE CLASSIC VIDEO
GAME, NEARLY 40 YEARS AFTER IT
CAME OUT.
THE GAME IS SIMPLE.
ROTATE AND FIT TOGETHER FALLING
BLOCKS OF VARYING SHAPES TO
CREATE SOLID ROSE.
YOU ALL KNOW.
THAT THE FURTHER YOU GET, THE
FASTER THE BLOCKS FALL.
TETRIS WAS CREATED IN 1984 BY
SOVIET ENGINEERS.
THE STORY OF ITS COLD WAR
INTERCEPTION TURNED INTO A
MOVIE THAT CAME OUT IN MARCH.
>> POETRY, ART,, MATT ALL
WORKING AND MAGICAL
SYNCHRONICITY.
>> IT'S THE PERFECT GAME.
>> TETRIS.
>> I DON'T GET IT.
>> THIS ACTOR PLAYS THE VIDEO
GAME ENTREPRENEUR RODGERS AND
THE STORY OF HOW HE SECURED THE
RIGHTS TO TETRIS, TAKES US
BEHIND THE IRON CURTAIN INTO A
WORLD OF DECEIT AND TREACHERY.
HANKS DETERMINATION TO BRING
TETRIS TO THE MASSES SYMBOLIC
OF THE FASCINATION GAMERS HAD
AND STILL HAVE WITH THE CLASSIC
GAME.
HANK ROGERS JOINS US NOW LIVE
FROM ST. LOUIS IN MISSOURI.
FIRSTLY, JUST WHAT IS IT ABOUT
TETRIS THAT CAPTIVATES THE
WORLD DECADES AFTER IT WAS
FIRST INVENTED?
>> I THINK THAT THE BASIC
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN TETRIS AND
OTHER GAMES IS THAT TETRIS IS A
CONSTRUCTIVE GAME.
YOU ARE NOT SHOOTING AND
KILLING ANYTHING.
THIS MAKES IT A GAME THAT WORKS
FOR THE REST OF US.
I MEAN, NON GAMERS.
>> YOUR STORY IN THE FILM ABOUT
PARACHUTING INTO THE SOVIET
RUSSIA IN THE GAME IS
ESSENTIALLY JUST REMARKABLE.
GIVE US A SORT OF QUICK 12 ON
HOW THAT ALL UNFOLDED.
>> I WAS A PUBLISHER OF
COMPUTER GAMES IN JAPAN AT THE
TIME AND GAME BOY CAME BACK OUT
AND I THOUGHT TETRIS WAS THE
PERFECT GAME FOR GAME BOY.
IT TURNS OUT I WAS RIGHT.
AND SO I GOT ON A PLANE, WENT
TO THE SOVIET UNION WITH A
TOURIST VISA AND SEARCHED OUT
THE PEOPLE WHO HAD THE
COPYRIGHTS.
AND I'M AT THE AUTHOR OF TETRIS
THAT IS 1989.
AND THE MOVIE KIND OF DEPICTED
THE, HOW CAN I SAY, THE DANGER
OF ME GOING THERE AT THE TIME.
>> YES.
AND LISTEN, YOU KNOW, WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT MY ERA, I
REMEMBER WHEN IT CAME OUT, I
REMEMBER GAME BOYS.
AND I --
ANYBODY WHO IS TOO YOUNG TO
KNOW HOW DANGEROUS THINGS WERE
BEHIND THE IRON CURTAIN BACK IN
THE DAY SHOULD GET TO SEE THIS
MOVIE.
I WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
WATCH THE SCENE FROM THE FILM
WHICH DEPICTS THE FIRST TIME
YOU LAID EYES ON THE GAME BOY.
HAVE A LISTEN.
>> THE GAME IS NOT JUST
ADDICTIVE.
IT STAYS WITH YOU.
THIS IS A ONCE IN A LIFETIME
OPPORTUNITY.
>> HENK ROGERS, ONLY TEN OTHER
PEOPLE IN THE WORLD HAVE SEEN
WHAT YOU'RE ABOUT TO SEE.
IT'S CALLED THE GAME BOY.
>> IT PLAYS TETRIS.
>> CAN YOU GET US THE RIGHTS?
>> [LAUGHTER]
IT STILL MAKES YOU LAUGH.
YOU CLEARLY HAD AN EYE FOR
POTENTIAL.
TALK US THROUGH WHAT WAS
RUNNING THROUGH YOUR MIND AT
THE TIME?
>> WELL, AM I GOING TO PULL
THIS OFF?
OR AM I GOING TO END UP IN A
GULAG?
THAT IS WHAT WAS RUNNING
THROUGH MY MIND.
I REALLY HAD NO IDEA.
IT IS LIKE GOING TO NORTH KOREA
TODAY.
AND WALKING INTO A MINISTRY.
IT IS NOT ALLOWED.
SO I WAS DOING THINGS WHICH
WERE NOT ALLOWED.
AND I GOT AWAY WITH IT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> YOU HAD THE FORESIGHT TO
PAIR TETRIS WITH THE GAME BOY.
AGAIN, WE LIVE IN A WORLD, AN
ERA OF THEY MAY, YOU GAMING NOW,
AND IT ALL FEELS SO FAMILIAR.
IT WAS NOT.
TAKE US BACK, HENK, IT WASN'T
BACK IN THE DAY.
YOU ARE A PIONEER, EFFECTIVELY.
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, ONE WAY OF
LOOKING AT IT IS I WAS A
PIONEER.
BUT IF YOU LOOK AT IT FROM
TODAY I WAS A DESIGN THIS OR.
--
THAT WAS A PERIOD IN THE GAME
INDUSTRY WHEN WE WERE STILL
PROGRAMMING IN MACHINE LANGUAGE
AND YOU COULD TELL BY THIS KID
THAT BROKE THE GAME THAT HE
WENT INTO AN AREA OF MEMORY, OF
THE COMPUTER MEMORY, THAT THE
PROGRAMMER NEVER ENVISIONED IT
WOULD END UP IN.
THAT IS WHY THE PROGRAM
CRASHED.
AND REGARDLESS --
>> IT CERTAINLY DIDN'T CRASH
WHEN I HAD A GO EARLIER ON.
LOOK, I WILL SHOW THE VIEWERS.
THIS IS CLEARLY NOT MY FORTE.
I WILL SAY, I CLEARLY DID NOT
SPEND A MISSPENT YOUTH ON A
GAME BOY BECAUSE IF YOU HAVE A
LOOK AT WHAT I ACHIEVED TODAY,
IT WAS PRETTY RUBBISH.
LET'S HAVE A LOOK.
>> WHERE AM I GOING?
OH NO!
>> NO!
[LAUGHTER]
>> OH MY GOODNESS.
>> [LAUGHTER]
OKAY, I'M NOT 13, CLEARLY.
I STRUGGLED AT MY RIPE OLD AGE.
HOW GOOD IS THIS 13 YEAR OLD
KID TO GET TO THAT STAGE OF THE
GAME, HENK?
>> ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
HOW MANY YEARS HAS IT BEEN?
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT 1989.
1989.
THAT IS AN INCREDIBLE AMOUNT OF
TIME.
>> 35 YEARS.
35 YEARS.
>> 35 YEARS IT'S TAKEN SOMEBODY
TO GET TO HIS LEVEL.
AND THERE ARE SEVERAL KIDS AT
HIS LEVEL NOW, BUT I MEAN, THAT
IS SUCH AN AMAZING
ACCOMPLISHMENT.
WHAT IT DOES IS IT SHOWS ME
SERIOUS TO TERMINATION.
YOUNG PEOPLE IN THESE COMPUTER
GAMES SHOW US SERIOUS
DETERMINATION.
IT IS THIS DETERMINATION THAT
WE NEED IN THE WORLD TODAY TO
FIGHT CLIMATE CHANGE.
THIS IS THE MISSION THAT I'M ON
NOW, TWO AND THE USE OF CARBON
BASED FUEL.
AND THESE YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
SHOWING US THE WAY BECAUSE IF
THEY CAN BEAT TETRIS WE CAN
BEAT CLIMATE CHANGE.
>> THIS IS FANTASTIC.
I HAVE TO ASK YOU, HOW GOOD ARE
YOU AT TETRIS?
>> I WOULD SAY I'M BETTER THAN
YOU.
[LAUGHTER]
IN THE DAY OF GAME BOY, YOU,
KNOW YOU GO TO THE VERY END OF
THE GAME YOU GET THE SPACE
SHUTTLE TO COME OUT.
I'VE DONE THAT MANY TIMES.
SO I GUESS I'M IN THE TOP 10%.
BUT NOWHERE NEAR THESE KIDS.
>> YES OF COURSE YOU, DO YOU
GET THE SPACE SHUTTLE.
I'VE NEVER SEEN THAT SPACE
SHUTTLE.
I NEVER HAVE, I NEVER WILL.
BUT NO WHERE AS GOOD AS THE
13-YEAR-OLD IS WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING.
WHAT AN ABSOLUTE PLEASURE TO
HAVE YOU.
THE MOVIE IS FANTASTIC.
GOOD TO HAVE.
YOU LET'S TALK AGAIN ABOUT YOUR
CLIMATE CHANGE SOLUTIONS AND
THE WORK YOU'RE DOING BECAUSE I
THINK THAT'S FASCINATING.
WE WOULD LOVE IT ON THE SHOW.
WE'LL HAVE YOU BACK.
THANK YOU.